>> THE WHITE HOUSE STILL NOT
AGREEING TO A NO-FLY ZONE.
>> HELLO THERE.
WELCOME BACK.
FIRST, THE GOOD NEWS.
OUR OWN BENJAMIN HALL IS OUT OF
UKRAINE AND I HEAR IN GOOD
SPIRITS AFTER BEING SERIOUSLY
INJURED.
WE ARE VERY RELIEVED TO HEAR
SOME GOOD NEWS.
FINALLY, BEN AND I HAVE
SOMETHING IN COMMON, WE BOTH
SUFFER, HE'S IN A HOSPITAL WITH
STRANGERS AND I HAVE MY
MOTHER-IN-LAW LIVING WITH ME.
A CHARMING DEMEANOR.
I'M JUST GOING TO TELL EVERYONE
HE IS IN ONE DIRECTION AND HOPE
I GET THE LEFTOVERS.
>> DISGUSTING.
>> AS WE ARE ON THE BRINK OF
WORLD WAR, WHAT ARE THE MEDIA
GENIUSES OBSESSING OVER?
DID YOU SEE THE ATLANTIC
MAGAZINE'S TAKE ON UKRAINE THE
HEADLINE ON TOP OF EVERYTHING
ELSE, NUCLEAR WAR WOULD BE A
CLIMATE PROBLEM.
YES, THAT'S THE PRIORITY COUNTR
GETS VAPORIZED, BUT IT'S ALSO 1
DEGREE WARMER FOR THE
SHELLSHOCKED SURVIVORS AND GOD
HELP THEM, IF YOU'RE A
RADIOACTIVE ZOMBIE YOU MIGHT
FORGET TO SORT YOUR RECYCLING O
TRY APPLYING THAT LOGIC
ELSEWHERE, YOU MIGHT GET
TERMINAL CANCER, BUT IMAGINE
WHAT THAT DOES TO YOUR TENNIS
ELBOW.
BUT IF IT WAS THE MEDIA IT WAS
THIS MYOPIC, THE HOUSE DEMS WAN
BIDEN TO CLEAR AND NATIONAL
CLIMATE EMERGENCY.
WHY NOT?
CLIMATE EMERGENCY IS THERE
SECOND FAVORITE FREAK OUT WHEN
BLAMING EVERYTHING ON RACISM
WANTS TO TAKE THE NIGHT OFF.
THE GLAUCOMA TO BAN OIL DRILLIN
ON FEDERALLY IN.
THE LECTER IN LOCKSTEP WITH WHA
PUTIN WANTS FOR US TO BE
DEPENDENT ON OTHER COUNTRIES
LIKE HIS FOR ENERGY.
PERSONALLY, I THINK ALL THIS
GREEN TALK IS RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA
.
THAT'S RIGHT, IT'S YOU THAT ARE
PRUDENT PUPPETS, NOT ME.
SPEAKING OF, PRUDENT CLAIMS HE
NOW WANTS REPARATIONS FOR ALASKA
.
I SAY WHY NOT, HOW ABOUT 40
ACRES, ENJOY BEHAR.
THE DEMS ARE ALSO CALLING TO EN
FOSSIL FUEL SUBSIDIES.
I'M FOR THAT IF I FOSSIL FUELS
THEY MEAN THE FIVE BOTTLES OF
INSHORE THAT JOE DRINKS A DAY.
HOW DOES THAT HELP THE AMERICAN?
IT DOESN'T AND THAT'S THE POINT
IT'S PART OF THE IDEOLOGY OF
PUNISHMENT WHICH IS NOT JUST TH
NAME OF MY FAVORITE CLUB
DOWNTOWN, I HAVE MY OWN WHIP
LOCKER, BUT IT'S ALSO HOW THE
LEFT VIEWS POLICY.
THEY DON'T MIND HIGH GAS PRICES
THEY WANT THEM TO PUNISH US FOR
BEING GREEDY CAPITALISTS IF I
SOUND LIKE AOC RIGHT NOW, THAT'
A POINT TO.
ENERGY POLICIES ARE BEING SHAPE
BY SOMEONE WHO SHOULD BE MAKING
BANANA DAIQUIRIS AT APPLEBEE'S.
THIS IS ALSO WHY THEY DENIED TH
CRIME BRAVE AND LET VIOLENT
THUGS OFF SCOTT FREE.
APPARENTLY ASIAN ELDERLY ASIAN
WOMEN MUST'VE BEEN SLAVES TOO.
THEY ALSO HAD RIGHTS IN PROTEST
THAT IS PUNISHMENT FOR YOUR
SYSTEM.
AND OF COURSE, YOU SHOULD WEAR
MASKS INDEFINITELY YOU SAY
BECAUSE THEY DESERVE IT, IT'S
NOT ABOUT SAFETY IT'S ABOUT
PUNISHMENT.
OTHERWISE THEY WOULD WEAR MASKS
AT THEIR OWN AWARD SHOWS AND
GALA EVENTS.
THEY DON'T WANT YOU TO BREATHE
FREELY WITHOUT THEIR PERMISSION.
MORPHINE POLITICS INTO REALITY
BECOMING A NEW RELIGION IN WHIC
THERE IS NO FORGIVENESS ONLY
CONFESSION FOLLOWED BY PENANCE.
BLESS ME FATHER, FOR I HAVE
SPENT, I JUST FILLED MY F1 50
WITH UNLEADED.
OKAY, SAY FIVE HILL GROTTOES AN
READ TO FIT YOUR HOUSE WITH
SOLAR PANELS FRIGHTENS
EVERYTHING THE LEFT WANTS IS
BASED ON PUNISHING YOU IT'S OKA
IF IT HELPS OUR ADVERSARIES.
LIDS TAKE RUSSIA WHO DUPED
EUROPE INTO DEPENDING ON THEIR
ENERGY, AS WE STATE TO START TO
SHUN RUSSIAN OIL REFINING OUT
THEY FUNDED GREEN GROUPS THAT O
NON-RUSSIAN FUELS, THEY WERE
USING MISINFORMATION TO STEER
COUNTRIES AWAY FROM FRACKING AN
SHALE GAS IN FAVOR OF THEIR
IMPORTED RUSSIAN GAS.
IT'S THE EQUIVALENT OF SETTING
DOWN REHAB CLINIC SO ADDICTS
WOULD GO BACK TO THEIR OLD WAYS.
IT MAKE SO MUCH SINCE NOW.
OF COURSE, YOU NEED TO BE A
SUCKER TO GET SUCKED.
WE HAD LEADERS WHO TOOK--THAT
CAME OUT IN A WEIRD WAY.
WE HAD LEADERS THAT TOOK
ENVIRONMENTAL ADVICE FROM A BRA
LIKE GRETA FROM BURKE AND A
RESIDENT THAT DREAMED OF
SNIFFING HER HAIR.
THAT'S BECAUSE THE IDEOLOGY OF
PUNISHMENT MEANS PUNISHING OUR
INDUSTRY BY BOLSTERING THERE IS.
WE ARE THE OPPRESSOR.
NOW, THE RESIDENT BLAMES BOUDIN
FOR RISING PRICES, IT WAS HIM
AND HIS STUPID PARTY ALL ALONG
GREAT IT TAKES MONTHS TO AFFECT
OIL AND GAS PRICES.
THE ANTI- INDUSTRY POLICIES FRO
THE TIME HE FIRST SOILED THE
OVAL OFFICE CARPET.
THEY KNEW WHAT EASY MARKER WHIT
HOUSE WAS, THEY WERE HAPPILY
PLAYING CHESS WHILE OUR BOZOS
GOT LOST IN THE ICE CREAM SLOPE
OF CANDYLAND.
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS,
HE IS SO BRITISH HE HAS HIM FOR
BREAKFAST.
AUTHOR AND POLITICAL COMMENTATO
DOUGLAS MURRAY.
HE DRESSES FOR THE JOB HE WANTS
SAILBOAT CAPTAIN.
RADIO AND PODCAST HOST SHE IS S
WIRY, YOU WANT TO HANG CLOSE ON
HER, FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT
TIMPF FAIR.
>> ALWAYS PICKED LAST FOR THE
SEESAW.
TYRUS.
SO GOOD TO SEE YOU AS ALWAYS.
>> SIR, I LIED.
BUT I AM CURIOUS I AM REALLY
CURIOUS ABOUT WHAT YOU THINK
BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T TALKED SINCE
THIS INVASION I WAS CURIOUS WHA
YOU THOUGHT OF HIS SPEECHES
MORNING, I'M JUST CURIOUS HOW
YOU VIEW WHAT IS GOING ON.
ARE WE BEING PULLED INTO A WAR?
SHOULD WE BE PART OF THIS?
I FEEL LIKE WE'RE BEING PULLED
IN AND NOW I FEEL LIKE AFTER
THAT SPEECH, WE HAVE TO HELP TH
GUY, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> I FEEL LIKE THE TRAJECTORY
HAS BEEN MOVING TOWARD GREATER
U.S. INVOLVEMENT PRETTY QUICKLY.
IT WAS A FEW WEEKS AGO WHEN I
THINK YOU WOULD'VE HAD YOUR
BIPARTISAN CONSENSUS, BUT THAT
IS OUR WAR.
WE'VE LEARNED THAT FOR 20 YEARS
OF MIDEAST AND SOUTH ASIAN
INTERVENTION THAT WE WANT TO
STAY OUT OF THINGS, ESPECIALLY
WHERE WE DON'T HAVE A CLEAR
OBJECTIVE.
RIGHT NOW OUR OBJECTIVE WOULD B
TO STOP THE RUSSIANS.
EVERY MORE AND MORE ABOUT THE N
FLY ZONE LAST WEEK THAN I DID
THIS WEEK.
I THINK PEOPLE FIGURED OUT WHAT
A NO-FLY ZONE WOULD ENTAIL WHIC
WAS IMPORTANT AND I'M GLAD THAT
THAT NOW HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED.
IT MEANS YOU HAVE TO SHOOT
RUSSIAN PLANES OUT OF THE SKY,
INCLUDING ON RUSSIAN SOIL
BECAUSE THAT CAN GO ABOUT FOUR
OR 500 MILES.
YOU HAVE TO DO A WHOLE LOT OF
BLOWING UP THINGS HE WOULD BE
UPSET ABOUT AND HE WOULD HAVE T
HAS THOUSANDS OF NUKES.
WE ARE GETTING LOTS OF WEAPONS,
I HOPE WE HOLD THE LINE NOT
ACTUALLY DOING THE FIGHTING
OURSELVES, BUT I'M NOT 100
PERCENT SURE WE WILL.
I'M HOPING.
>> I HAD AN IDEA FOR A STORE
THAT ONLY SOLD BOXER BRIEFS
CALLED NO-FLY ZONE.
DOUGLAS, ENGLAND INVADED LOTS O
COUNTRIES, ADMITTED SPIRIT WHAT
IS YOUR TAKE ON THIS.
WHAT YOU THINK OF THIS?
>> I AGREE THAT SORT OF AN
OBVIOUS THING THINGS THAT WE CA
DO.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE WE DON'T
SPARK WORLD WAR III.
BUT, IT IS A PRETTY TIME BECAUS
WE SEEM TO HAVE BEEN LURCHING
FROM DISASTER TO DISASTER IN TH
LAST FEW YEARS THANK GOD THE ON
GOOD THING THAT HAPPENED WHEN
HOOTON INVADED UKRAINE AS WE GO
RID OF TONY FAUCI.
AEGIS DISAPPEARED.
AND, SAME THING IN THE UK, THE
COVID ADVISORY BOARD DISBANDED.
IT'S LIKE WE CAN DEAL WITH ONE
MASSIVE EVENT AT A TIME BEFORE
THIS WE HAD COVID AND BEFORE
THAT WE HAD TROMP.
WE HAD ALL OF THAT, WE HAD
RUSSIAN COLLUSION OF COURSE AND
THERE HAS BEEN RUSSIAN COLLUSIO
IN RECENT YEARS, AND IT'S ONE
THAT NOBODY BOTHERED TO TALK
ABOUT, PARTICULARLY ON THE LEFT
WHICH WAS RUSSIA FUNDING ALL
THESE GREEN MOVEMENTS AND OTHER
COUNTRIES LIKE MY COUNTRY NOT T
FRAK.
THIS WEEKEND OR IS JOHNSON GOIN
AROUND THE MID EAST HAVING THEM
PUMPED MORE OIL, THEY ARE
FILLING AND THE TWO SITES IN TH
UK WHICH IN FILLING THEM WITH
CEMENT, NONE OF THIS MAKES SENSE
, IT ONLY HAPPENED BECAUSE
THE RUSSIANS TERRIFIED US
THROUGH THE GREEN LOBBY THAT
FRACKING CAUSED EARTHQUAKES AND
TSUNAMIS INSTEAD OF A RUMBLE
THAT IS NO BIGGER THAN THE
AVERAGE FREIGHT.
>> IT IS AMAZING BECAUSE YOU
THINK ABOUT FOR THE PAST TEN
YEARS, ALL THIS STUFF, ALL THE
DOCUMENTARIES, ALL THE HOLLYWOO
CELEBRITIES, ALL THE STUFF ABOU
FRACKING.
IT MIGHT HAVE ALL BEEN DRIVEN B
THEM.
>> BECAUSE WHEN THEY GET THE
SCRIPT, THEY NEVER ASK YOU WROT
IT.
IT SOUNDS GOOD.
WE HAVE THE UNCOMFORTABLE TRUTH
AND THEN THE LATEST THING WHERE
A NUCLEAR WAR IS GOING TO BE BA
FOR THE CLIMATE, DO YOU THINK?
IT IS DESIGNED TO WIPE OUT ALL
LIFE, THE GOOD NEWS IS FOR THE
WOKE IS THAT ONCE THE GIANT
CLOUD OF DEATH FILLS OVER THIS
GUY, THE EARTH WILL COOL 2
DEGREES, SO IT WILL BE A
LITTLE COOLER IN THE ASHFIELD
WORLD WE ARE WALKING AROUND IN
WITH NO WATER YOU CAN DRINK, BU
WE WILL BE COOLER.
SO YES THEY ARE RIGHT, IT WILL
BE BAD FOR THE ENVIRONMENT AND
EVERYONE WITHIN 7 MILES OF IT A
FIRST AND THEN EVERYONE WITHIN
400 MILES OF IT BECAUSE
RADIATION TENDS TO GROW.
SO THEY'VE GOT IT RIGHT, THEY'R
JUST NOT EVEN CLOSE ON GETTING
IT RIGHT.
>> I JUST HOPE THAT IF THERE IS
A CATASTROPHIC CLIMATE CHANGE
AND NUCLEAR WAR, THAT THEY
CANCEL EACH OTHER OUT.
RIGHT?
>> THEY ARE BOTH GETTING
UNFOLLOWED BY ME ON TWITTER, 10.
>> I'M GOING TO MAKE CLIMATE
CHANGE MY AVATAR JUST TO SHOW
THAT I AM INVOLVED.
>> I'M IN IT WITH YOU.
>> #WE DON'T LIKE BAD THINGS.
>> IT'S GOING TO BE IN A CURRENT
.
>> YOU KNOW I LIKE THE NUTS.
>> I DID THAT TO MYSELF.
>> KAT, I WANT YOU TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE SECRET
AGENDA THAT RUSSIA DID, DID YOU
WATCH KAYLEIGH, DID YOU SEE IT
THIS MORNING?
>> DID IT MOVE THE NEEDLE AND
YOU KNOW THE NEEDLE I'M TALKING
ABOUT.
FOR GATE NOT THE ONES I INJECT
MYSELF WITH WHEN I'M DOING DRUG
ON THE STREET ALL DAY EXCEPT FO
WHEN I'M SITTING RIGHT HERE.
I'M GLAD YOU SAID THAT BECAUSE
DO USE SO MANY INTRAVENOUS DRUG
SPIRIT.
>> DO NOT PUT WORDS IN MY MOUTH.
YOU WEREN'T THINKING WHAT I WAS
THINKING.
LOOK, I THINK HE PRESENTED A
GREAT CASE, BUT IT SO IMPORTANT
WE DON'T START WORLD WAR III AN
I THINK I AGREE THAT IT'S SO
GREAT THAT PEOPLE UNDERSTAND
WHAT NO-FLY ZONE MEANS NOW
BECAUSE ALL THE POLLING REVEALE
THAT PEOPLE FOR A NO-FLY ZONE
THEY SAY OH, THAT ACTUALLY
INVOLVES US HAVING TO SHOOT DOW
RUSSIANS AND THEIR LIKE I DON'T
WANT THAT, WELL THAT'S WHAT THA
IS.
I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
OBVIOUSLY TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
DON'T GET INVOLVED IN SOMETHING
LIKE THAT, ESPECIALLY, WE'RE IN
AFGHANISTAN SO THAT'S OVER SO
NOW WERE GOING TO SEND THE
TROOPS OR ELSE, THAT'S PRETTY
AWESOME.
>> THERE'S LIKE A SPECTRUM OKAY
ON THIS SIDE YOU HAVE IRAQI, AN
ON THE SIDE YOU HAVE WORLD WAR
II.
YOUR HEART SAYS THIS IS LIKE
WORLD WAR II, BUT YOUR MIND SAY
WHAT IT'S A BACK.
WE WENT INTO IRAQ TALKING ABOUT
DEMOCRACY, AND WE [BLEEP] UP.
>> AMERICA HASN'T WON A WAR AND
A QUARTER OF A CENTURY, AND
THEY'RE WEARING ONCE WE GO IN
AGAIN.
BUT DID YOU SEE THIS, THERE WAS
A GREAT THING THAT HAPPENED IN
GUGGENHEIM WHERE I ALWAYS LOOK
TO FOR FOREIGN POLICY.
A COLLECTIVE OF ARTISTS TOOK
OVER THE GUGGENHEIM THE OTHER
DAY AND THROUGH PAPER AIRPLANES
BECAUSE THEY SAID THEY WERE FOR
NO-FLY ZONE AND THE GREAT THING
ABOUT IT IS IF THEY GET THEIR
WAY IN THEN WORLD WAR III STARTS
, I RECOGNIZE THAT THE
SAME ARTISTS ARE GOING TO BE
SAYING STOP THE WAR.
>> YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THEY
THOUGHT SAFE SPACE WAS NO LIKE
NO-FLY ZONE.
IT WAS THE CONFUSION, THEY JUST
THOUGHT THEY JUST DREW A LITTLE
LINE.
>> THE LITTLE CYBER AREA THAT
SAYS YOU'RE IN A NO TALKING ZONE
.
IN THIS WHEN YOU GET A MUSHROOM
CLOUD BEAR.
>> IT'S SO INTERESTING TO THINK
THAT MAYBE PEOPLE DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND THEY THOUGHT NO-FLY
ZONE WAS IN AGREEMENT YOU MAKE.
>> WE NEED AN